(playful music)
- Hi, my name is Sandrine Hazan
and I'm the Stranding and
Rehabilitation Manager
for the Sea Otter Program at
the Monterey Bay Aquarium.
Come on in and take a sneak peek.
The Otter Care Program at
the Monterey Bay Aquarium
takes in stranded, injured
and orphaned sea otters
to be rehabilitated and
released back into the wild.
So, we actually spend
the majority of the time
observing these otters in this office,
using our camera systems and the monitors.
This is a great tool for us
to be able to observe them
without directly impacting their behavior.
These are the current otters
that we have in-house.
And as you can tell the majority of them
have numbers for names.
And this is so that we
don't become attached
to these otters that
are going to be released
back into the wild.
Ivy is one of our resident
otters and she acts
as a surrogate for our orphaned pups.
Like all wild animals, it's
important for the public
to give them their distance.
Injured and orphaned otters can be very
dangerous and can bite.
They can easily transmit
diseases to humans as well,
which is why it's important
to keep your distance
and allow for experts to handle them.
Paul is prepping some food.
And what do we got?
We are currently feeding them, some squid.
This is definitely one of
their least favorite items
but it's good for them to have a variety.
Sea otters at the Monterey
Aquarium eat very well.
It is important that
they have a diverse diet.
Providing proper enrichment
is really important
for all age groups that are under our care
but specifically for pups.
This gives them the
opportunity to practice
manipulating objects, which
then translates to being able
to handle live prey as they get older.
Taking care of pups is a full-time job.
They get offered formula
approximately every
three to four hours.
And once they get older and
have the appropriate dentition,
we then start offering solid food.
Eventually we get them to the point
that they can recover food
and dive to the bottom
on their own, before
going in with a surrogate.
One of our primary goals,
when working with these
dependent pups is ensuring
their successful release
back into the wild.
And one of the ways
that we can do that, is
by helping to prevent imprinting
and habituation on humans.
We wanna to make sure that
they don't associate anything
positive with humans,
such as food or grooming.
In order to do that, we
need to disguise ourselves
to create a shapeless form,
that hides the human body.
So, since this pup is
going to be released back
into the wild, I want to
make sure to disguise myself
properly, so that she's not
associating anything positive
with humans and warm formula is definitely
something positive.
So, I'm going to be wearing this disguise.
First this, then a mask, cover my face,
which I'll have down,
once I'm in with her.
And then I also want a
way of protecting my arms
because like we talked about,
these otters have sharp teeth.
(bright guitar music)
(bright guitar music continues)
Once a pup has been weaned
from their surrogate,
they will spend more time in a tank
with different companion animals,
working on socialization,
continuing to learn how
to forage independently.
And, at the point, in which we
see that they are consistent
in their behavior, body
condition looks good,
coat condition looks good.
And around nine to 10
months is really the time
when we would start considering releasing.
Given that we spend so much
time working with these otters
and rehabilitating them
and having gone through
the surrogacy program,
we want to make sure
that there is a way that we can track them
and monitor their progress,
once they're released
back into the wild.
So, before they go, they are outfitted
with some of these accessories.
The first thing that they
get is a radio transmitter,
that is surgically
implanted in their abdomen.
And this transmitter will
be able to emit a signal
every time they're at
the surface of the water.
And if we have an antenna and a receiver,
we can find them and hear
them when they're foraging
or grooming at the surface of the water.
The other thing that they
will get are flipper tags.
Combination of two flipper
tags, one on each flipper,
so that we can visually identify them
when they're out in the water.
(gentle music)
(gentle music continues)
Visit the Monterey Bay Aquarium's website,
montereybayaquarium.org, to learn more
about how you can donate and help.
(gentle music)